the prime minister of the helic Republic
Mr kiriakos mitsotakis
[Applause]
good morning dear colleagues we have
with us today the prime minister of
Greece kiriakos mitzvotakis Carlos
prime minister thank you for accepting
our invitation to address the Parliament
and the people of Europe as part of our
this is Europe debates
Europe is after all a Greek word
and the birth of democracy in Ancient
Greece gave an impetus to a creative
spirit that produced the architecture
the Arts and the philosophy that have
shaped Western Civilization as we know
it
no Society before the Greeks start to
believe that order and freedom were
compatible and with the return of War on
our continent and power Politics on the
global stage we are reminded of the
importance of safeguarding democracy
hand in hand with our rules-based order
to preserve Freedom over autocracy
in over 40 years of membership Greece
has given the European Union influence
and stability in the Southeast
Mediterranean and no doubt Greece's
importance will continue to grow as a
new geopolitical reality unfolds
Greece will become an energy Hub
connecting the Greek electricity grid
with the Middle East and Africa will
soon accommodate Imports of lower cost
renewable energy into Europe and this
signals a new age for Greece this summer
we'll also see Greece exit the Euro
groups enhance the surveillance
framework which helped steer Greece's
economy out of a crisis which began 12
years ago it was not easy this year
marks the end of a cycle of restrictions
and closed monitoring a new era of
sustainable economic growth and
prosperity is opening up for Greece and
its people so today we salute Greece and
every Greek citizen for this important
Milestone achieved thank you dear prime
minister for being with us to Mark the
success Dia kiriakos the floor is yours
foreign
thank you madam president allow me to
address this house in in Greek
Madam president
ladies and gentlemen members of the
European Parliament
many many thanks for this uh invitation
to speak
as on behalf of Greece to the 27 member
states of our Union
at a time
which corresponds to the end of a very
difficult chapter for both Greece and
Europe but also with a start of new
joint efforts in the face of the major
challenges of the future which are
already knocking on the door of our
European family
now is the time to courageously
plan the European Union for the decades
ahead
in 2015
Greece
was one step away from the abyss of
leaving the European Union in its
Society then
there were waves of blind populism
striking time and time again
but on the 5th of July
2015
same date
a referendum was conducted
which almost gave the coup de grass it
was only
in the face of the
question of uh
an unregulated bankruptcy that the the
government
stepped back but there was a serious
effect on the banks the capital controls
and also a third
memorandum which took us to another
cycle of austerity
no European Society
has suffered more than Greek society in
the past decade luckily for my country
Greece in 2022
cannot be compared to Greece of 2015
seven years on
I am standing here before you
to say to you
that those images have been deleted
forever
my country has a new government
which is leading our country into a new
age
which wants to push development
reducing unemployment and increasing
increasing investment and in a month
from now
we will be shaking off the enhanced
surveillance framework so we are ready
over the next year
within 2023
to to
increase investment so we look to the
Future in a more optimistic fashion
despite the major challenges out there
but I'm standing here
in order to express a huge message of
thanks to Europe Europe that supported
my country when others
were questioning the whole European
approach
all of you
who helped
us
to stay as a supporter of democracy in
the most uh Democratic of countries that
was a sign of solidarity and we are
referring that back to Europe now in
aiming in pulling together towards our
common social objectives yes there have
been dramatic crises but we've learned
from them
so
who would really have believed some
years back
that
Greece which was at the end of the line
in terms of development in Europe 10
years ago will be third in line now who
would have thought
that Greece could achieve that by
reducing taxes three times but also
without threatening social stability who
would have believed some years back
that
Greek public service this symbol of red
tape would today be much more digital
and much more citizen friendly
so we have turned the page
we've changed
and
the Greeks themselves
um
they believe only in the truth of their
votes because they are now seeing the
results of the very brave measures
brought in by a reforming government
and the quality of our democracy has
also been improved and we've shaken off
the Neo-Nazi threat from Golden Dawn so
I'm very proud as a Greek to be able to
say that my country has taken control of
its economy it's changed its country
and it is now an active and equal member
of the European Union
Athens
was one of the first in line in
combating covid with
vaccinations
with the Greek proposal for your
European vaccination pass which was
adopted
it was also one of the first countries
to stress the need to shape a new
European fund for the recovery of our
economy's post covid one of the first
countries that actually had a national
plan for next Generation EU
that's not all because at the same time
Greece has stood as a guardian of Europe
in 2020 in March when on our Eastern
borders
there were constant threats of invasion
by tens of thousands of illegal migrants
from Turkey
I remember back then
in a action of solidarity
within 48 hours
on our borders on the Everest River the
president of the European Parliament our
beloved David sasoly was present the
president of the European Council and
also the president of the European
Commission
that is something which remains
dramatically present as we've seen now
what migrants are facing in Spain
but
we've seen also
the actions which are ongoing with the
Smugglers working on land and on sea and
unfortunately this is becoming more
frequent but as a European
uh
I would like to stress that the European
foundations have stood up to it and have
managed to find new solutions to New
Challenges
we have seen the European Bank uh
opening its doors to the
State bonds we've seen the European
semester there's been new mechanisms
introduced and
at the same time there has been constant
technical support for the general
director bringing in change but Europe
at the same time has supported Greece
working alongside it
along the path towards these major
changes
and it's
been clearly understood that National
challenges are often uh European ones so
there is no role for local egoism
we can only have solidarity
if the state towards that which that is
directed is involved as well so these
are the Dual foundations I would say of
this new European Construction
members of the European Parliament I
spoke at the beginning about the major
progress achieved by my country
in
2021 we showed High develops of growth
much better than projected about eight
percent we've seen an increase in
investment and a reduction in unemployed
unemployment and we have seen changes in
the public sector
Greece has met its final
commitments to the IMF two years ahead
of what was planned
we have got a better system we have
drastically reduced
um loans for Greek Banks and all of that
is being shown in the figures
I know
I'm speaking to Electric representatives
and so I would like like to raise two
issues which I think are very important
of something which has been achieved as
we followed this path
firstly the conditions within Greek
society was moving and secondly the
fundamental
measures brought in on the social side
to ensure that progress there in the
social side could be going hand in hand
with improvements on the economic side
and in the environment we have a new
approach under my government
uh hybrid attack and they've been
National threats in their Gene from
turkey and in the Eastern Mediterranean
which
expanded in 2020 they've been natural
disasters fires
and then we were hit by the storm of the
pandemic on all of these fronts we
always strove
to make crisis into opportunity with the
help of Europe we better organized the
protection of our Eastern borders
uh diplomacy well we entered into
agreements on the protection of sea
areas with Italy and Egypt Israel as
well links there
and
increasing our defense establishing
um serious conditions for Mutual
protection with France and also an
agreement with the United States
and
as I say we've made a crisis into a
driving force I think this is was seen
in
the pandemic as well because we've seen
a doubling of the
Awards available and staffing has been
taken on but this has become a reason to
study a new public National Health
System in my country already
we are moving towards a free public GP
for all and we're working on all areas
of primary and secondary care
and this leads me to my second
the second comment I mentioned about the
social
move despite the international and
National conditions
now this is a country which is coming
out of a very painful tragic
crisis financially and it's hit by
another but is is striving to remain
focused on its aims and support the
well-being of its Society throughout the
pandemic
we spent
tens of thousands to support
firms and workers we provided tax relief
to support Investments and support uh
Revenue we brought in major changes in
the working environment
with
policies aimed at lower taxes better
jobs and a better life
the increase in the minimum wage I think
has also helped in that direction we
have a digital Labor uh card now as a
shield against misuse of workers
they can show very clearly
um how the conditions of their work and
the hours they work
so we're adapting to European conditions
so there is no form of Distinction
discrimination anymore because the same
rules apply across the board to our
workers
in the face of needs
and any progress we've made we can't be
fully satisfied but this is the measure
of our effort
we have achieved many well-paid
jobs and this is something that all uh
we're all calling for across the
political Spectrum in the question of
training and education increased
investment a new
Vision which
focuses AT progress in the economy going
hand in hand with social progress
colleagues at the beginning I said that
nothing in Greece
or Europe
remains
the same
at the end of the second decade of this
Century but
there have been
unprecedented changes coming about
across the planet
The Invasion and provoked invasion of
Ukraine
War has returned to our planet It's
upsetting the energy situation
um and the effects are spitting over
into all European societies the
nightmare
of a shortage of food is re-emerging in
many countries around the world
and
we
know that for every country ever
organization
there is a question out there
on what side of the various interests
involved are we going to stand
because
we're going otherwise to end in a vacuum
the role
of Affair
partner has been mentioned many times
over history in Europe from the European
Parliament also
from Greece we've always answered the
question and from the very beginning we
are on the side of peace and an
international rule of law against an
invasion
and an infringement a violation of
borders we are for democracy and in a
Democratic Society and therefore we
refuse this
autocratic neo-depotism we
we always want to support
that approach they struggle in Ukraine
is
a turning point I would say in the
history of Europe the importance of
which is becoming visible
only if each
state does plays its role in line with
its own requirements we owe it to
Ukraine to reject
any form of uh approach like this which
could become another form of disruption
in the future and that's why
well it's particularly important for two
countries uh which are members of Europe
Greece and Cyprus because I'm talking
here about the ongoing threats from
Turkey
which is looking towards Europe
clear decisions from the European
Council have been taken now but we have
to stand up for the international rule
of law
in the face of provocation we have to
show readiness
in the Eastern Mediterranean
as we are facing the major challenge of
this war in Ukraine one thing stands for
sure
we do not need new uh
returns of these type of approaches one
thing is for sure
Greece
will not see anyone questioning its
National sovereignty and its territorial
integrity and I'm sure that in this
ongoing struggle we will have all of you
on our side
so my position has long been clear we
close the door to threats we keep the
windows open to attempts to achieve
peace sometimes well
differences between difference between
states must always be solved on the
basis of international law
so they're not only geopolitical
repercussions they also have economic
and social repercussions as well these
International disruptions are leading to
a rise in the cost of all products which
in turn
is giving rise to social discontent
logically throughout all of our
societies
so
we Face the risk of populism arising
once again we need
um
solutions to complex problems
and there are no magical solutions for
that Europe is therefore
being called upon to face many
challenges disruption
and the question of this dependency on
Russian energy we must move faster on
green
Replacements and we also have to look at
the question of energy prices as well
there's no doubt that
we have to deepen
democracy
in member states because inequalities
distances between our politicians Contin
peoples continue to exist
we should avoid
or we have to speak to our
citizens in a simple language every day
straightforward talking about their uh
real needs and speaking against fake
news all of this represents the path for
us to show that our national governments
and the European institutions
um are not
red tape they're a system which are
there to support All European citizens
Greece will be present for all of the
crises ahead we're one of the first
countries to join the European or
supported European energy plan
and
we are a constant Source a port of entry
for renewable energy coming in not only
to cover Greece's needs but we're
looking at the Balkans Eastern Europe
we are pushing ahead with our
connections with Cyprus and Egypt Cyprus
and Israel so that the entire continent
can be provided with clean cheap energy
from the Sun of Africa and the the
Middle East in the question of strategic
economy uh autonomy for Europe I would
stress once again that we have a
bridging role to play with the Balkans
and
we are also looking at the question of
common uh security within the framework
of
NATO
only
over the last
few months
we have saved 6
000 people in from the sea all of them
coming from Turkey
so
we need as I said at the beginning a new
plan to address this
for my country
I would like to say that as far as
democracy is concerned we have new
the Constitution we have elected the
first woman as the president of the
Hellenic Republic
we have passed large volumes of
legislation recently
um
many looking at the right to vote of
Greeks living abroad who will be able to
continue to vote and we've also adopted
unprecedented reforms covering rights
within Greece
now
ladies and gentlemen
it's not only about what's happening in
my country
or on the continent
we have to look at the Europe of the
future
which has to stand its grounds
it has to
establish its own defense and energy
policy building on what we have done so
far in the green transition
and on the Greece of cultures which has
to involve the entire world I should say
that despite the difficult circumstances
I am reading the situation with optimism
Europe
has was more effective in than many
other parts of the world in the face of
kovid
other large countries such as China
still hasn't got to to grips with it
it was a huge decision in Europe to have
the common vaccination policy
and also the question of exchange that
supranational level so that we were able
to support our economies throughout
Europe and we were able to overcome this
major covid
crisis
it would have been impossible for that
type of thing to happen three years ago
and so we are there in renewable
energies new technology we have a new
plan on climate change and I know how
interesting and difficult
tomorrow's debate is going to be on this
question of taxonomy but despite the
difficulties
democracy is always there in our
countries we have the will but we have
the culture of our peoples to build on
we have
liberal forces
such as the United States
as well who are looking progress
is there for us
the billions available under the new
fund which has been set up
and
we have to look at the title the role we
have to bring about uh recovery but uh
also we have to ensure that it is
resistant so
we have drawn the consequences I think
and then the lessons from the four major
challenges the crisis the pandemic and
now the energy crisis
what have we learned
firstly
that's in a connected world no
State can manage a crisis of these
Dimensions alone however big it may be
and secondly as I said when Europe moved
quickly with common mechanisms and
decisions
it showed that it was resilient
and with those two lessons I
would ask that we apply this now in the
face of this huge uh energy crisis
so
a United Europe
means
in energy terms United as well
we have to have the courage to intervene
in the markets
when they have basically stopped working
we have to break the link between the
costs of natural gas and the cost of
other energies and I see that now things
are moving within the commission to look
at the way in which we price electrical
energy on our continent and I'm saying
this as a
liberal-minded politician and I'm able
to look forward to the future I would
call for public Intervention when
markets stop working to the benefit of
the citizens
green economy with zero emissions
yes
it will exist but how we're going to get
there and how in the meantime are we
going to bring about a quick green
transition
without uh the the
budgets of our families being brought to
their knees these are the issues we have
to address over the next month
particularly in view of the hard winter
that lies ahead I know we have to work
together my country
we'll be providing a
2000 megawatts of new uh possibilities
for electrical energy this year we know
that we need further connections
and so that no country in the European
Union is excluded from the European
networks these are the major challenges
we're going to be faced upon to uh to
deal with
and we need a an agenda of resilience
and development for the whole of the
European Union
I'll conclude with this thought so
that's I'll leave some time to take your
questions
these are the major challenges we're
going to be called upon to face and to
respond to over the next years the
question of European Defense common
defense policy bearing in mind also the
migratory challenges
banking Union
and savings
a an effective European energy plan and
coordinated action
based on the RF
the deepening of democracy
addressing
um
fake news
demagogues and also the role of the
European Union in the western Balkans an
enlargement of Greece as a Balkan
country fully supports that enlargement
we want Europe in the Balkans but we
also want the Balkans in Europe
ladies and gentlemen we're all aware of
the fact that these are ongoing
struggles
well
the historian five years ago wrote this
in a book
that Europe fought for freedom and
achieved it and together with a
prosperity for all the world the call
for Unity and the clear feeling of
identity continues to exist
but the only certainty is the
uncertainty which affects our lives and
I will close on that adding that it is
our duty to protect
Freedom the freedom and the prosperity
which have been achieved by previous
generations for our benefits but we also
have to fight for the European identity
we want it but our first duty is to make
stability a fact because in the current
circumstances the strong States strong
states are stable States
and that will strengthen the European
Union it will be strong in its stability
for the benefits of its citizens I would
like to thank you very much indeed for
having given me the opportunity to speak
today to the European Parliament
thank you
thank you very much dear prime minister
dear kiriakos we now give the floor to
the leaders of the different political
groups starting with the leader of the
Epp group The Mumford weather
president your Commissioners your prime
minister
on the 7th of July 2019
almost exactly three years ago you won
Greek elections in the landslide Victory
Greek people sent a strong message of
support and Trust to you and to near
democracy to steer the future of Greece
and turn a page on failed policies of
Alexis Cyprus and sirisa when you came
into office Greece was in bad shape I
think that was obvious after painful
years
of poor leadership by Cyprus
you put Greece back on track and thank
you for this remarkable and excellent
work thanks to you and thanks to your
government Greece is back in Europe and
that is good news
it is important for Europe
to have Greece back first of all
everybody I think should and must
underline that Greece is in a way not a
normal country because democracy was
born in Greece our western civilization
was born in Greece Europe was born in
Greece and uh not to mention the princes
taking away by soys the beautiful greed
the princess who gave her name to our
all joint project Europa there is no
Europe without Greece
greases back on economic issues last
year even in crisis times Greek economy
grew by more than eight percent when it
comes to gross Greece is among Europe's
top five countries
you managed to reduce the unemployment
increase
in Greece in the quarter from Summer
2019 to February 2022 more than any
other country you did it and the people
feel the success in their daily life
thanks to your efforts and to the
determination of the government Greece
is finally also on the way to exit their
surveillance program
on another aspect Greece is back and
that is about the security issues since
you took over Greece seriously cares
about security again Greece due to its
Geographic position is a key when it
comes to the European security
Europe is not to be criticized but to
thank Greece for protecting and
defending our common external borders
and I want to be very clear on this when
I see that each and every single event
on the border between turkey and Greece
is in this European Parliament an issue
then it's okay that we discuss the
issues but on the other hand we saw in
Spain on the Spanish maroc American
Border an event where more than 20
people died and I have to tell you that
the Socialists and greens didn't
initiate the debate about the events in
Spain but the debate they initiate
always a debate when it is about Greece
so we should care about the migrants and
not about party political issues when it
is about migrants I have to be clear on
this that EPP is strongly on the side of
our Greek
authorities
the other one is misusing migrants as a
political weapon like lukashenko did it
for us that's clear
our border guards who are doing every
day the job are protecting people and
the border and we trust them we are
respecting their work every day in the
interest of all of us what we have to do
is to strengthen frontex and we have to
do is Also to clarify the rules for
pushbacks and I want to thank
margaritasquinas for his work in this
clarification process
Greece is back also on geopolitical
issues Cyprus I have to say mainly care
about Maduro you care about the European
interests in the Mediterranean and that
is good
not only in the last years do we witness
an increasingly destabilizing role
played by turkey dangerously raising the
tensions in the region what turkey is
doing is unacceptable
it is not a problem between Greece and
Turkey
but a problem between Europe and Turkey
Greece interests are European interests
and disorder conflict and we all have to
ask us and probably Mr Prime Minister
you can reflect a little bit in your
final statement
how do we best deal with Advanced turkey
a turkey that is becoming more and more
provocative and aggressive
and greases back on foreign and defense
issues Putin and the other one tell us
one lesson Europe must grow up when it
comes on foreign and security policy it
is great news that Finland and Sweden
finally joined the European at the NATO
and as an Epp our parties in Finland and
Sweden always fought for becoming NATO
members the Socialists finally also
supported this uh approach the Epp is
fully supporting NATO but he also thinks
that Europe has to grow up we must
abolish the unanimous vote principle in
the council side when it comes to
Foreign Affairs and within the NATO we
have to build a true common European
Defense with concrete projects like a
cyber Brigade
or a European missile defense system
Europeans have to be capable to defend
themselves if it is needed and if you
allow me I want to finalize with a more
General consideration because you
delivered Mr Prime Minister a great
speech in the U.S Congress and Senate a
few weeks ago
it was a big honor for you to be there
as one of the European leaders
and when we look to the U.S and we also
look to our European Democracies we have
to
see that these democracies are under
stress we are facing population and
extremism
and the probably most fundamental
question is can we agree still in our
societies about what is true what is the
reality
because we have fake news discussions
you mentioned this we have propaganda
from China from Russia which tried to
change
what is true the reality which we are
based on and without a common
understanding in our societies about
what is true what is the reality you
cannot build up a lively Democratic
discussion between green socialist Epp
and so on and so forth and people cannot
decide that's why the idea to strengthen
these come in this common base is so
important fight against propaganda too
often it is unanswered you have to
strengthen good and serious Shona listen
and we have to make clear that the tech
Giants have a responsibility we will
vote this week on dma and DSA which
would give and will give an answer on
these challenges so thank you dear
kiriakos thanks to you Greece is back in
Europe the Greek people can be proud
about these achievements
thank you
thank you Mr Weber and now on behalf of
the snd group Nicos Andrew luckis
over the last
decade Europe has faced the crisis after
crisis which has increased inequality
and has
meant that we have to all stand together
to face the crisis
um
as
we've seen for millions of Europeans the
possibilities for a better life being
reduced and we've been
seeing therefore increasing threats to
uh to liberalism
now the forces in Europe have allowed
the deniers of the European
construction to exploit that and this is
the duo we have to face up to as you
said yourself some weeks ago
and
I am speaking for the more concerned
about the more conservative forces in
Europe if they do nothing we won't be
able to face up to this crisis
popularism elitism they are just as
catastrophic for Europe but the world is
changing and we have to be up to the
changes we need to do more and to do it
now we have to have a progressive
framework towards solidarity protecting
human rights and protecting the
environment we have to make our citizens
feel safe again in the face of
geopolitical climate and economic
economic challenges of our times we have
to
establish recovery and resilience as a
constant uh characteristic particularly
in the German the Greek peoples who have
faced such difficult situations we need
to strengthen the resistance of our
scientists societies and economies it's
good to remember the the referendum back
in 2015 but let's be fair we also
remember very clearly the
humiliating times of 2019 which
brought our country into a facing major
deficits and we knew that the challenges
were out there and that was them that
opened the Pandora's Box in Greece so we
have to talk about our young people we
have to create new opportunities in
order to reduce migration we have to
strengthen the markets according to
euros that
the Greek citizens are facing much more
than other European
citizens there is not much protection
for them uh in terms of what other
European countries with similar problems
have done
public investment well it's crucial that
we do something about that as well we
have to look at the question of primary
care and the National Health System we
have to make sure that we have a lever
to develop further sources of energy
through the various funds available to
us
now throughout the European Union the
aim is to decarbonize the economy but
you are a
following a slightly different path as
the laws recently uh introduced in your
country's show the European commission
is given the possibility to have
National plans to upgrade also energy
possibilities in our countries using all
the necessary sources so that we can
Source
cleaners become more energy autonomous
and have fairer distribution we also
have the
the disastrous invasion of Putin in
Ukraine it's a dreadful disaster for the
Ukrainian people and a lesson for all of
us in Europe how can we Face up to these
leaders
as we've seen there are no results
coming about we need some serious
methods to be uh to be
established we need uh steps to be taken
in terms of the foreign approach
through after 10 years of ongoing crisis
the Greek people has lost a huge amount
of its GDP and it's now spending a
fortune on the sovereignty uh in in
defense measures and defense spending to
support our sovereignty so we need a
decision to be taken on an embargo
vis-a-vis turkey and Mr Weber you were
talking about supporting well okay but
you personally voted against in the past
and also its pointless heads of European
States adopting measures when they
support erlogan erdogan if it continues
to do what it's doing is automatically
looking like a terrorist State
colleagues
we have to look at violations of uh
rule of law it's crucial for all of us
and we as
should ensure that
um everyone in Europe feels safe across
the board so we need serious changes to
ensure that finally we do have a common
foreign defense and security policy at a
moment in history where these nightmare
scenarios which are threatening our
borders and they're coming back to the
past all of us all of us we must give
new breadth to the European dream we
have to ensure that we can look to the
future with more optimism and hope for
All European peoples the renew group
Malik asmani
foreign
the attention of solidarity of all of us
the unjust and unquote war of aggression
raised by Russia in Ukraine is
triggering new crisis
and energy crisis
four shortages and these two combined
will lead to an economic and perhaps
migration crisis
this continent needs to get ready for
all of these and doing so while helping
the ukrainians fight their good fight
and it's quite simple
Mr Putin must fail
therefore we must stand by the Ukrainian
people with determination
and sanctions alone are not enough
to ensure Putin's failure
Ukraine needs our happy weapons and here
all of us have a duty to back our words
with actions
there is one man responsible for the
food crisis
that's
Vladimir Putin
food shortages risk many vulnerable
adults and children
and they also have a risk of a migration
crisis for Europe
and I'm quite certain a new migration
crisis would seem very attractive to Mr
Putin but we cannot let him succeed
we need to finalize a new European
migration and Asylum Pact
we need a strict Affair system for the
whole Union to work but we need the
whole Union to take its responsibility
and we need to do it now we have waited
for too long and the next migration
crisis might be at our doorstep already
the council needs to move and this house
needs to engage in pragmatic negotiating
with them to reach a deal before the end
of this year
dear colleagues
I'm worried when I read some of the
reports of violent deportations
and yes we must uphold Euro
and yes we must protect new borders
and yes we must ensure turkey abides by
its obligations to us
but we say no to Illegal pushbacks of
any kind
in Spain in Greece or anywhere else
foreign
minister
I hope you can agree with us in Europe
that the Europe of today needs to be
bold so we can address the cost of
living crisis facing Europeans
like the common Solutions we found for
the pandemic
in Effective Thinking is needed to
address our energy challenges we need to
boost our economic credentials by
signing the free trade deals that are
frozen
to deal with New Zealand last week shows
us the way
protectionism is no antidote
to inflation
by investing in a modernization of our
economies by embracing competition by
improving our entrepreneurial and
investment climate
we can continue to sail the ship of
prosperity
let's be bold
and fight back against global economic
headwinds
and then finally their colleagues
we see that in many countries even
within the European Union the values and
principles that breathe life into our
democracies are under attack
and I will be frank prime minister as
always
we are worried about the decline in
press freedom and media pluralism in
Greece
the warning lights are flashing
Greece now has the worst performance in
EU 27 as far as media freedom is
concerned
Mr Prime Minister
I hope you agree with me that media
freedom is Central to our European way
of life
every new Europe has added at this
distinguished Greek map Mrs Georgia
schedule to its ranks it's sitting over
there on the first row
our family expects the voice of its
representative to be heard according to
European media rules and standards
we don't want to see another EU
government leaders Landing the Free
Press
because as you know it was Socrates who
said
when the debate is over
slender becomes the tool of the loser
and we are aware that some in your
political family have set a bad example
the police prime minister don't follow
in their destructive footsteps stop
administ prime minister and stop
silencing Mr crystals and stop it now
hold the Prouds of the Greek tradition
of public debate alive and you will
continue to find Renew at your site
facing the crisis ahead together in
unity
thank you
thank you I give the floor next on
behalf of the green group to
tinekastrich
thank you chair commissioners
the Prime Minister welcome in our house
and also minister of European Affairs
during the Eurozone crisis we have
painfully witnessed in Greece how
citizens suffer if the EU fails to act
in unity and solidarity and citizens
should never anymore pay the price of a
dysfunctioning monetary and economic
Union Chris should be able to count on
the union to fully reap the benefits of
the green transition
but we also count on Greece to defend
the fundaments of the Union a Euro based
on Democracy rule of law media freedom
and non-discrimination
a Europe that respects fundamental
rights including human dignity and the
right to apply for Asylum
and I wonder is this Europe as well
prime minister
if Asylum Seekers try to enter this
Europe through your country their rights
are brutally trampled they are pushed
into the Turkish Waters and land
migrants are even forced to push back
other migrants and the Border guards are
most men putting lives at risk enjoy
impunity but those whose safe lives are
convicted
and therefore I ask you Mr mitsutakis is
this Europe
you're closing down the most human camps
a force Asylum Seekers to live in remote
and closed hot spots you leave thousands
of Asylum Seekers from Syria and
Afghanistan in a legal limbo using the
fiction that they could return to Turkey
which they can't and the lucky refugees
that do get a status have to survive on
the streets
yet those helping refugees are
restricted and criminalized those who
speak up including media are silenced
but prime minister covering up evidence
doesn't help because the reality is
recorded and reported Time and Time
Again by all relevant bodies of the UN
Council of Europe by Ombudsman ngos an
investigative journalists and European
judges refused to accept this reality as
it violates EU Asylum law
that Mr mitsarcus is Europe
and let me be clear other members says
have put Greece in an unfair position
they breached the principle of
solidarity by refusing a common
responsibility for Asylum Seekers we
could be allies in combating these
selfish policies and to have
geopolitical answers to geopolitical
conflicts but sealing off the borders
deterring and pushing back refugees is
not the European answer
and instead of trying to demonstrate the
shield for Europe I urge you to solve
the many problems in your Society
people are suffering from it the
36.8 percent young people unemployed
the high level of poverty the increasing
use of fossil fuels right in this Global
crisis instead of investments in
renewable energy
use the EU funds to create Innovative
green and social jobs to transform your
country into an inclusive modern and
sustainable state
prime minister we count on Greece to
honor the fundamental rights on which
true European solidarity can be built
both for the Greek citizens and for the
refugees because there is no Europe left
to protect or to defend if its core
values are undermined thank you
thank you Miss trick I give the floor
next to Gunnar Beck on behalf of the ID
group
thank you presidents
prime minister submits to talk is
welcome to the European Parliament
I'd like to congratulate you more than
once
first on paying off your debt to the IMF
two years ahead of schedule
however
the euro is quite another matter
it's not served Greece well
quick inflation stands at 12 percent
rents in Athens are up about 17 percent
and petrol prices are approaching three
Euros per liter
almost 30 percent of Greeks are at risk
of poverty or social exclusion
one million Greeks work in the tourist
sector but the rental costs of sun beds
in exclusive resorts in Mykonos now
equal the monthly minimum wage in Greece
prices
of up to 110 percent for Greek hotel
rooms far exceeders in other holiday
destinations
layoffs in the Greek tourist sector
therefore seem inevitable
second
I'd like to thank you for your efforts
in protecting Europe against the ongoing
migrant invasion last week you decided
to Triple the length of the Border fence
with turkey and you prevented Smugglers
from offloading over 1 000 illegal
migrants on Greek Islands third I
applaud your resolve in resisting
aggressive posturing from Ankara
Greece's territorial integrity
should be sacrosanct to the EU
more self-evidently say that that of
neighboring non-eu countries
I had probably to start I firmly
disagree with you on the expansion of
the European Empire
with the highest inflation rate since
the 1970s this is not the time to waste
energy and money on making the Western
Balkans fit for 55. rather we should
focus on the Greek pension on
384 Euros per month at the 14 million
Germans who live near or below the
poverty line
further your government recently decided
to follow Germany in ordering F-35
American fighter jets instead you could
have favored European options to protect
European not American workers and jobs
finally
at a recent press conference on
demographic change you seem to adopt the
logic of replacement migration
commending the integration of
populations from Asia and Africa as a
viable alternative
or as a viable solution to low fertility
rates
instead of favoring imaginative family
policies Hungarian Style
the truth is that European governments
have failed us for
40 years even Europe's richest countries
were never Rich enough to allow both
families to raise two or three children
in modest comfort
there are now importing billions of
migrants which will rarely work and
usually live on welfare
sadly
are easily our EU leaders are destroying
our welfare state through the back door
and European culture and civilization
with it prime minister I implore you to
resist Fonda lines great replacement
Greece was under ottoman rule for
centuries you have no reason to adopt
Germany's guilt complex
I give the floor next to Emmanuel
Francos on behalf of the ECR group
foreign
Minister thank you very much for coming
along today as a young Greek
I'd like to look at the problem of the
brain drain
a problem of people particularly
scientists leaving Greece looking for a
better future with of course negative
consequences for Greece
I was in the aristotelio University in
Thessaloniki
recently and I was given the same kind
of choice that lots of my colleagues had
trying to leave in order to find a job
and in it seems that about half a
million Greek students and graduates
have left the country with a huge cost
to the National budget
who's to blame for this obviously
unemployment first of all eurostats
figures have shown that
Greece is number one in terms of youth
unemployment in unit in Europe with
figures of 30 percent
if you're 25 to 30
you are much more likely to be
unemployed than the average citizen it's
difficult therefore to look for jobs
within Greece and
this means that they have to do young
Greeks have to do often jobs which have
little to do with what they study
obviously education isn't free the cost
has been estimated about 33
000 Euros per student
and if these people go to another
country that has been wasted it's only
damaging for Greece if that kind of
thing happens
we need of course therefore to encourage
people to find a well-paid job
by staying in Greece
and it's something has to be something
that's to do with what they actually
studied
this is a problem for Greece and the
European Union
we don't have a kind of ecosystem which
would allow young people to find a job
using their own understanding and
learning
it's important therefore that we try to
persuade people to stay in Greece so
that they're not clients but citizens so
that they can raise a family and face up
to the huge population problem that
Greece is facing
it's important therefore that we deal
with this issue
and I mentioned another problem the
population problem
the average family in Greece has 1.2
children and we actually need to have
two children per family if degrees as a
nation is going to survive uh young
people scientists have told us need
to come back home the ones who have left
because of the grain the brain drain
if the country is going to survive
they do come back home if they've
studied abroad or worked abroad in other
countries we have to ask ourselves why
they're not doing the same thing in
Greece
not a great deal has been done to
address this problem so I'd like to ask
you two questions about that issue prime
minister first of all can Greece attract
Mac all of those Greeks who left the
country during their crisis years and
secondly what are you going to do
personally to try to address this
problem thanks very much Madam president
thank you Mr Francos next on behalf of
the left group Dimitris
foreign welcome to the European
Parliament Mr mitotaki
let me begin
at the start by saying that during your
government it's impossible to hide from
the first second of what you were saying
the problems that your government has
caused Mr Weber and Mr Mr Takis
you started with a personal and attacks
on the government of Mr cipras
let me say that things like that
simply show that you already still
afraid of the government of Mr tipres
and what it achieved
the
prime minister in the past was Mr tipra
now it's Mr Mr tagus in the future in my
Mr Cyprus again and you should respect
the truth and the truth says
that the ND party the new Democracy
party is largely responsible for the
bankruptcy of the country
because of the enormous amount of
debt and the oligarchs and the enormous
amount of debt
they signed up to the
memorandum the with the Samaras
velizelos government
the banks were destroyed enormous
amounts of unemployment in ormond's
amount of
retrograde steps taken as far as social
conditions were concerned
it was almost like race was before they
joined the European Union 40 years ago
that's what you should have been telling
us about in your speech Mr Victor jacket
Greece has got the highest inflation in
the European Union
12 much higher than the rest of the
eurozones the most expensive Petrol in
the European Union Euros that has said
that an enormous amount
of prices are higher increase than in
other parts of Europe we've got
not just
unemployment and
inflation we've also got bankruptcies
like hurry now as companies go bust
we're also 26 out of 27 as far as fresh
freedom is concerned
and do you really think that
reporters Without Borders who came up
with these figures are just
an NGO tried to interfere in Greece we
believe that it's a partner of the
European Parliament the Council of
Europe as well and along with the
president of the parliament metzola
there's going to be a meeting of the
with reporters Without Borders of people
you've just been attacking so tell us
why Greece is still top of the league as
far as
unemployment is concerned and 26 out of
27 when it comes to gender equality
we've got some of the worst performances
in Western Europe as far as the pandemic
response was concerned as well as Mr as
man from the
renew groups and is strict from the
greens the need to make sure that
illegal behavior is carefully monitored
particularly when it comes to things
like
freedom of the press
because things aren't going well in
Greece as far as things like that are
concerned there's the question of the
survival of the rule of law
called for
modernization and speeding up of reforms
in Greece
and some people seem to think
that properly functioning legal system
is a barrier to investment
in the Greek Parliament recently you
mentioned certain Greek journalists and
you said some insulting things about
them
the highest court in the land
people who see to the question of
Justice
and they found that those journalists
were completely innocent of the charges
which you had leveled against them
but you should at least apologize to
them for the things that you said
I am coming to an end man and president
Portugal
is with its money from the recovery and
resilience fund
coming up with
plans to help young couples and students
what are you doing with that thanks very
much
the future that the EU is preparing for
working people is one they're living in
already with
poverty unemployment rocketing prices
energy poverty and green taxes which are
financing the green and digital business
this has happened with all governments
increase including the ND the new
democracy government today who are
promoting the criminal policy of the
green the changeover the phasing out of
lignite and putting money putting
energy onto the stock market now you're
weeping crocodile tears about who's
going to be paying for these changes and
the consequences of the sanctions
against Russia it's working people who
are going to be paying for them as
extremely expensive us LNG is being
brought in this anti-working class
policy it also entails the breaking of
links among working people the ex the
removal of collective debt bargaining
and your government calls on the people
to get used to living with unemployment
benefits and in misery unemployment
benefit doesn't cover anything like the
huge increase in prices as huge
inflation becomes more and more rampant
all of these things in your speech show
what the situation really is
the
there's no basis for what you are
claiming is happening
the huge
failure to use the recovery and
resilience fund properly at the same
time the danger of spillover from the
Ukraine is growing
and once again working people are going
to be suffering because of the
agreements that you've entered into with
NATO
if Greece gets involved that would mean
that we'll simply be serving the desires
of NATO which will then be providing and
producing even more refugees what we
need to do is try to protect ourselves
from Turkish aggression and this is
opening the way through yet more
exploitation of what's happening in the
Aegean
the Greek people
have moved from pasok to series Earth to
syrizer to new democracy only the people
can save the people there is a
solution which is an increase in workers
struggle fighting against vat the high
taxes on fuel all of these low wages and
low pensions provided by the system
which pays for imperialist Wars with the
assistance of NATO and the European
union we need to start taking with
riches where they can be found
colleagues who have taken part in this
debate I invite once again the prime
minister
mitsatak is to respond you will see that
there is quite a lot of commotion but
that's because members are coming to
prepare for the vote and they would I'm
sure be happy to listen to your replies
okay thank you um
Madame President
let me quickly address some of the
points uh raised by uh your colleagues
first of all uh
thank you Mr Webber for making the
observation which I think is fair that
Greece is indeed back because the
country today objectively Bears no
resemblance to the country that we took
over when the Greek people placed our
confidence in Us in July 2019 I think
the progress that we have made is rather
objective in terms of the performance of
our economy and in terms of the
intensity of the reforms that we have
implemented I would like to very much
take note of what you said regarding the
importance of structuring our democratic
debate be that the European Parliament
or within our national government based
on true facts rather than rumors or fake
news it is impossible to have a proper
debate if we continue to question the
basic facts and let me take note of a
point uh raised by Mr papademulis when
he falsely claimed that Greece has been
the leader in the European Union in
terms of covet death per million people
this is a lie Mr papademulis it's plain
false and it is unacceptable that you
show up in this house and replicate this
type of misinformation so let us at
least get our facts straight when it
comes to the issues pertaining to the to
the public to the public debate I think
it is very important to make sure that
we can have a public discourse based on
facts that are mutually acceptable
let me switch to to Greek to quickly
respond to Mr randallakis I'll switch
back to English for the rest of my uh
answers
I listen carefully to your observations
Mr Andrew lackeys on the Recovery Fund I
can assure you
that are proposals for the fund have
been accepted by the European commission
they have a very powerful social
component
and what we were doing is spending the
money on combating unemployment
supporting
smes trying to improve the situation in
general the
energy saving programs that we've put
together
will help All Greek households
particularly the ones who are poorest
they'll have Priority Access
on the weapons embargo on Turkey let me
just say
that probably every European country
is free to export weapons
but we need very carefully to bear in
mind in all European countries
the situation which exists in the
Mediterranean
we have a country that has Ambitions to
join the European Union turkey and
openly calls into question the
sovereignty of another country which has
the fortune to Good Fortune of being a
member of the European Union that is
something which European countries need
to Bear very carefully in mind when they
take decisions
and their choices on the selling of
weapons to third countries respond
respond to some of the points made by Mr
Osmani
I took note
um Mrs money of your observations
regarding press freedom in Greece
I can assure you Greece is a country
where everyone can write and publish
anything about anyone without any
censorship or any control by the
government just uh take a look and I I
printed them here they're just you know
two indicative front pages from today's
newspapers which accused me of being a a
a liar a sycophant and these are daily
daily front pages from at least four
daily newspapers in Greece and the same
media Freedom applies to TV to radio and
of course the internet where everyone is
free to write anything about anyone and
I would urge you uh to take some of
these rankings which are published by a
non-governmental organizations with a
grain of salt
does one really believe in this house
that countries such as Chad in Africa
have more media freedom than Greece
because this is exactly what was
presented in the rankings which you
claimed anyhow when it comes uh uh so
when you when you get advice from your
new renew colleagues I suggest you dig a
little bit deeper in terms of the
reality of of the Greek public discourse
we are a very Dynamic and vibrant
democracy and I can assure you uh that
freedom of uh of the press is an
accepted reality in Greece for many
decades now and frankly you know the
commission is going to publish its
recommendations uh regarding rule of law
we expect them uh and we will look very
carefully at what the commission has to
say and at the end of the day I think we
kind of trust the commission to properly
assess the state of rule of law in all
European countries
Mr strick thank you for your comments uh
and I think you've raised some um uh
valid points first of all regarding the
lack of solidarity offered to Greece but
also to other countries which are on the
external borders of the European Union
when it comes to the migration issue I
would however like to to point out that
it is the right of every European member
state to protect its borders with full
respect for fundamental rights this is
exactly what Greece has been doing for
the past three years and we have been
successful in protecting our borders and
we have been successful in terms of
breaking down the Smugglers networks
that have really exploited the
desperation of weak and traumatized
people by encouraging them to embark on
a very dangerous journey and when you
speak about pushbacks I would urge you
to think more in terms of push forwards
rather than pushbacks we we have a
statement between the European Union and
turkey which requests turkey to
cooperate in terms of managing migration
flows across the Aegean won a Sailing
Boat Leaves a Turkish Marina with a
hundred or two hundred people on board
I think we need to be naive to believe
that this is happening without knowledge
of the Turkish authorities we know very
well that turkey back in March 2020
weaponized the migration issue and tried
to push tens of thousands of desperate
people across the Greek border exactly
the same practice that lucasenta did in
Ukraine there was nothing different The
Playbook was written already by turkey
back in March 2020 so please when you
look at these issues which are sensitive
issues let us not repeat the Turkish
propaganda that they have no role in
what is happening and that it is you
know the Greeks who are behaving
inhumanely in terms of not protecting
fundamental rights we have an
independent anti-corruption agency which
is looking at allegations some of the
allegations yes are concerning and they
need to be further explored having said
that I would like to point out that the
reception facilities because you made a
point to the reception facilities today
bear no comparison to the reception
facilities under the previous leftist
government take a look at the islands
now go visit Samos or Hills you will
find state-of-the-art reception
facilities that were funded by the
European Union which have no comparison
to the disgrace of maurya which was a
creation of the previous leftist and
very sensitive quote unquote when it
comes to Human Rights
issues this reality no longer exists one
last point in terms of integration I
think you will find this interesting
yesterday I welcome to my office a 19
year old Iranian boy his name is kurosh
kurosh made it to lesvos in 2019 he
entered a Greek school he learned Greek
he gave his entrance exams to Greek
University and he will now be admitted
to the best school in Greece when it
comes to electrical engineering having
aced his National entrance exams this is
how this government looks at the
integration process of people who have
reached the European Shores and have a
right to be integrated into the European
Society
now
um when it comes to
um uh the points raised by Mr Beck and
Mr frangoulis um very quickly
um Mr Beck I assure you that when it
comes to uh purchases of weapon system
uh all the important weapon systems that
we have purchased over the past three
years have been European and I do
believe that we need to purchase more
European systems when we have that
option and I we I believe we need more
integration of our defense industry in
order to make it more competitive and
when it comes to the issues raised by Mr
frangos
regarding the The Brain Drain I can
assure you that for the first time many
young Greeks who left the country over
the past decade in search of a better
job are seriously contemplating
returning to the country for two reasons
because for the first time we offer many
good paying jobs and because they have
an overall confidence that this country
is moving in the right direction we
still have a lot of work to do to
reverse the brain drain problem but I
think we have made some important First
Steps finally
finally when it comes to the points
raised by Mr Papa di mulis who was very
very eager to defend the previous
government I understand uh his point but
I think it is improper sometimes that
I'm president to bring issues pertaining
to domestic politics to this house I
would only point out one reality Mr Papa
de mulis seven years ago there was a
referendum which was led by your
government which pushed Greece to the
precipice to the precipice of us exiting
the Eurozone and it was only because you
reversed the decision of the Greek
people you made the famous
which is a somersault a U-turn that you
signed the third program and essentially
condemned Greece to four unnecessary
years of austerity this is the reason
one of the main reasons why you were
voted out of power and why we came into
power in order to make sure that we move
Greece back to a proper uh growth attack
finally when it comes to again issues
regarding uh rule of law uh we'll have
an opportunity Madam speaker and I will
end here to have a discussion in the
Greek Parliament tomorrow regarding
these issues
what is a fact today when it comes to
Independent Justice is that two of the
closest collaborators of Mr cipras the
minister in charge of anti-corruption
has been sent to the highest court of
the country accused of tampering with
Justice and intervening Injustice and
the second minister of Empress
government has also been sent to the
highest court because he interfered in a
public tender regarding broadcasting
rights so this is a track record of your
government you have two of your
ministers who will be held accountable
to justice for Clear interventions when
it comes to rule of law so let us back
and the facts speak rather than use this
chamber to promote fake news thank you
again Madam president for giving me the
opportunity to address the European
Parliament
thank you prime minister
thank you dear colleagues
this closes the debate
and we go to the votes